[Musica]
quando mi chiedono di parlare di realtà
virtuale io non so proprio da dove
partire è impossibile raccontarla potrei
partire da Aristotele il suo pensiero
filosofico su quello che è il concetto
di realtà e invece no voglio raccontarvi
di me erano gli anni 70 e i miei
genitori mi fecero un regalo una cosa
curiosa un oggetto che non avevo mai
visto Eccolo
qua l'oggetto è questo La magia del View
Master è stato inventato nel 1938 negli
Stati Uniti ed era un'evoluzione di
quella che era la possibilità di vedere
delle immagini tridimensionali
attraverso dei Semplici visori delle
cartoline tridimensionali in bianco e
nero all'epoca La magia del Blaster era
incredibilmente più grande perché
mettendo il visore sugli occhi si aveva
l'impressione di essere lì Lì dove lì
nelle fotografie di questo cerchietto
sono sette fotografie per ogni disco
tridimensionali che danno l'illusione di
trovarsi proprio in quel posto in quel
momento non avevo avevo circa 8 anni non
ero grande e non avevo ancora capito di
trovarmi fra le mani un oggetto che
poteva rappresentare proprio quello che
nel futuro sarebbe potuta diventare la
realtà virtuale adesso io voglio farvi
provare questo oggetto così ve lo
passate intanto che racconto le cose lo
potete guardare e Vedrete come vi
meraviglierà se non lo conoscete perché
non siamo abituati a vedere le cose in
questo
modo come dicevo All'inizio la realtà
virtuale è difficile da raccontare
Allora mi è venuta in mente una cosa
quando la tecnologia me l'ha permesso
circa 6 anni fa ho invitato degli amici
a sperimentare un
visore perché ho detto se qualcuno non
può prov
l'ebrezza e l'emozione di avere un
visore Forse qualcosa può arrivare
guardando le emozioni che il visore può
[Musica]
provocare in cielo Ma che
cazzo
no Che
figo
No ma che mondi
sono S io son po di vertigini
No
minchia
Ok
salve
[Musica]
non ci credo dove
sono No ragazzi
pazzesco qu
[Musica]
toccato
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Ecco la realtà virtuale è un'esperienza
che si può solo vivere forse nelle
emozioni dalla Dalle facce che hanno
fatto i miei amici avete capito che
qualcosa succedeva in quella maschera
qualcosa che era incredibilmente
reale tanto per raccare un po' le cose
voglio intanto definire la realtà
virtuale la realtà virtuale è un mondo
completamente ricostruito che possiamo
vedere per esempio attraverso un visore
Ma che rispetta le regole della fisica
per cui se per esempio io in realtà
virtuale vado addosso a un muro e il
muro mi fa fermare cioè io posso anche
andare avanti ma nel visore vedo il muro
e basta Non posso oltrepassarlo se
invece cado da un balcone io cadrò
davvero perché la fisica vuole questo
Allora possiamo fare un passo avanti e
parlare di di realtà artificiale la
realtà artificiale è un passo in più
perché può Non
rispettare la logica della fisica di
conseguenza io posso vedere un muro
davanti e attraversarlo e andare da
un'altra parte cosa che in realtà non
potrei fare Oppure potrei cadere da un
balcone e
che è un'esperienza
incredibile però mi sono domandato alla
fine se la realtà virtuale è qualcosa
che noi abbiamo nella nostra vita Voi
direte ho bisogno di un visore e invece
se ci pensate il concetto di realtà
virtuale l'abbiamo tutti i giorni quando
sogniamo quando sogniamo viviamo
esattamente questo tipo di esperienza
una realtà ricostruita nella nostra
mente
una realtà che va al di là anche della
fisica è una realtà però che non
possiamo governare e quindi la domanda è
se potessimo costruire una macchina dei
sogni non sarebbe fantastico e ci stiamo
arrivando grazie alla tecnologia
naturalmente l'ultimo elemento è il
ciberspazio è stato introdotto nell'84
del romanzo di Gibson neuromante e
racconta di spazi
dove insieme potremo interagire ed è la
direzione esatta verso la quale stiamo
andando oggi è vero che oggi si parla
anche di metaverso ma il metaverso è una
cosa differente perché il metaverso non
ha per forza a che fare con la realtà
virtuale noi possiamo andare in quello
spazio che è il metaverso attraverso Sì
un visore ma anche attraverso uno
smartphone un PC il metaverso riesce a
inglobare pare tutto per cui c'è una
differenza tra realtà virtuale che fa
parte del metaverso e invece il
metaverso
che richiede anche ma non
necessariamente la realtà
virtuale torno un po' indietro per
raccontarvi di come l'uomo abbia sempre
cercato di trovare un modo per vivere
delle realtà che non erano vivibili in
quel momento Nel 1950 per esempio venne
creato autotest
una sorta di videogioco chiamiamolo così
molto diverso da quello che abbiamo in
mente Oggi dove due giocatori due
autisti dovevano sfidarsi guidando per
finta delle automobili finte perché
quello che avevano davanti era
semplicemente un
filmato quando il volante aveva una
direzione diversa rispetto a quella
dell'automobile filmata c'era un blocco
e di conseguenza si perdeva del tempo
perché la macchina non seguiva il vostro
nostro volante veramente semplicemente
era un filmato e quindi andava per conto
suo il primo ad arrivare avrebbe vinto
ma era un modo per cercare di far
entrare qualcuno in un ambiente diverso
erano gli anni 50 il mito
dell'automobile e quindi chi non poteva
permettersela almeno aveva un surrogato
di quello era un tentativo c'era anche
l'odore del tubo di scappamento per cui
la sensazione quasi era proprio quella
di di guidare qualche anno più tardi
Siamo nel 1000 956 e Morton healing
inventa il sensorama il sensorama è una
sorta era una sorta di View Master solo
molto più grande dove si infilava
completamente la testa e si vedeva un
filmato tridimensionale a colori con il
suono stereofonico che quindi dava
l'idea ancora di più di immersività gli
odori Quindi ancora di più i suoni
Ovviamente come ho detto e le
vibrazioni per cui la sedia si muoveva
in rapporto più o meno a quello che si
vedeva addirittura c'era il vento
Insomma l'uomo ha sempre cercato di
creare delle macchine dei sogni l'ha
fatto anche Nintendo nel
1994 creando il Virtual Boy forte del
successo del del Game Boy l'idea eraa
quella di fare una console portatile
Questa è portatile per modo di dire
perché va appoggiata su un tavolo
bisogna mettersi lì con gli con gli
occhi all'interno come vedete è ancora
una sorta di View Master Se ci pensate
Questa volta però le immagini Sono in
movimento hanno soltanto due colori per
ragioni tecniche Il rosso e il nero e si
poteva videogiocare con la sensazione di
immersività
stavamo arrivando a quello che oggi è il
visore per la realtà virtuale io ho
portato questo Semplicemente perché è
uno degli ultimi che sono sono stati
costruiti pensate che non serve neanche
più il computer non bisogna essere
necessariamente Collegati a un computer
perché tutta la tecnologia è qua
all'interno le telecamere Sono
all'interno ci sono anche i controller
Ma io posso non usarli perché il visore
permette di vedere le mie mani
chiaramente costruite virtualmente e
usare quelle per cui abbiamo sempre
oggetti più piccoli vicino a noi per
entrare nel mondo della realtà virtuale
l'idea potrebbe essere quella di unire
la realtà fisica con quella virtuale per
quello mi ha fatto stupore vedere questo
oggetto che è stato costruito da
un'azienda italiana se non mi sbaglio e
che rappresenta un calcio ballilla tutti
Avete giocato la cosa bella è che
fisicamente i giocatori hanno in mano le
manopole muovono le manopole le girano
per Peccato che non vedono assolutamente
niente perché Come vedete non ci sono
gli omini Ma hanno i visori perché in
realtà loro stanno vedendo
questo Quindi fisicamente muovono le
manopole e loro nella realtà virtuale
Sono all'interno di uno stadio dove c'è
gente che urla c'è gente che fa il tifo
La partita è azionata e come vedete ci
sono i giocatori che si staccano
addirittura dalle bacchette per esultare
durante un gol qualcosa che con il
biliardino normale non sarebbe
possibile la realtà virtuale può entrare
nelle nostre case in tanti modi è
utilizzata molto dalla medicina in
questo caso anche per quello che è la
ripresa fisica come vedete Qui abbiamo
un tennista che ha subito un trauma e
grazie alla realtà virtuale riprenderà
il il movimento del braccio il concetto
è che quando il nostro Ello fa degli
esercizi fisici e fine a loro stessi si
annoia andare in palestra Infatti se non
c'è niente da fare sollevare i pesi Ci
annoia Ma se invece abbiamo un visore
che ci dà l'illusione in questo caso di
giocare una vera partita di tennis Beh
allora la noia passa e il cervello fa in
modo che il nostro malessere possa
guarire più in
fretta abbiamo la realtà virtuale
abbiamo la realtà aumentata quelli che
vedete sono i Google glasses che non
hanno avuto grande successo anzi non
sono neanche più commercializzati l'idea
era quella di vedere le cose come io sto
guardando voi Voi state guardando me
sovrapponendo delle informazioni
all'inizio avrebbero dovuto essere un
grande successo Se n'è parlato poi sono
stati usati soltanto
diciamo in ambito industriale e poi sono
stati
abbandonati poi abbiamo la realtà mista
che mette insieme tante cose La realtà
virtuale e quella aumentata nell'altra
foto vedete sullo smartphone un gioco
che è Pokémon Go che permette di vedere
attraverso la videocamera del telefonino
il luogo dove siete magari proprio qui
in questo Chiostro e trovare un Pokémon
con il quale potete interagire il
Pokémon chiaramente è ricreato
dall'intelligenza artificiale dal
programma però lo vedete lì fisicamente
sembra addirittura vero perché quello
che riprendete è vero bene tutto questo
sarà quello che ci aspetta nel futuro
tutto questo insieme di cose io non so
dove andremo Perché il limite per ora è
ancora il visore Come avete visto quello
è un limite invalicabile e quindi
potremmo ridurlo sempre di più ma ci
vorrà Però potrebbe davvero essere il
nostro futuro l'anno scorso nelle radio
italiane andava in onda questo
spot molti credono che il metaverso sarà
solo virtuale ma un giorno i vigili del
fuoco useranno la realtà aumentata per
orientarsi più rapidamente negli edifici
in fiamme guadagnando istanti Preziosi
per salvare più vite i medici potranno
visualizzare le immagini diagnostiche
nel metaverso e prendere decisioni più
rapide in emergenza anche se i mammut
sono estinti nel metaverso gli studenti
potranno tornare all'era glaciale per
visitare il loro mondo il metaverso è
uno spazio virtuale ma il suo impatto
sarà reale Ecco è molto vero il
metaverso la realtà virtuale sono spazi
virtuali però l'influenza può essere
veramente reale Allora In conclusione io
posso dirvi questo che al di là di
quello che si pensa possa essere la
realtà L'esperienza di realtà virtuale
ci permette di capire qual è il nostro
rapporto con le realtà non soltanto
quella che viviamo ma quella nella quale
possiamo immergerci e la cosa
straordinaria è che in questa realtà
quella virtuale non ci sono confini di
nessun genere nemmeno di tempo e nemmeno
di spazio quindi godetevi se potrete la
realtà virtuale
[Applauso]
Grazie Y